et à vous dites télémark et manuellement
ou concentre à lui tout seul tous les
pouvoirs aujourd'hui mais qu'il veut
garder tout ça c'est la constitution qui
l'est concentre à l'excès rêve là il
veut renforcer cela et il veut
technocrates is et le parlement et au
lieu d'en faire une assemblée souveraine
de représentation du peuple on faire une
espèce d'assemblée technique
consultative
remplissez pas d'odeur entendu dans son
discours à versailles oui très ouvert
sur le parlement il donnait une série de
modifications et de modernisation du
parlement oui mais par exemple ou au
sénat en ce moment les propositions qui
ont été votées hier sauf par un groupe
lenôtre et qui vise à supprimer le débat
en séance publique sur toute une série
d'amendements possibles c'est à dire on
est en train de restreindre le et
n'envisage même on envisage même dans ce
qui a été voté hier ce qui est
incroyable que quand un projet de loi va
venir on débat on puisse soustraire une
partie des articles de ce projet de loi
au débat en séance publique pour
l'examiner vous et dangereux comme il
est dangereux de faire ch 1 c'est le
débat en séance publique c'est le moment
de vérité et de transparence un polype
assez vite aujourd'hui comprenez pour
aussi c'est fait non je ne pense pas que
ça je pense qu'il faut au contraire
arrêté avec l'inflation législative et
avec l'accélération du travail
législatif à la c'est ce cri parce que
il faut que nous ayons le temps de
discuter avec la société des projets de
loi regardez ce qui se passe sur notre
dame des landes quand on va trop vite en
parlera très bien et bien on peut faire
n'importe quoi et c'est vrai de beaucoup
de sujets en l'état s'il ya une une
convocation du congrès donc députés et
sénateurs à versailles vous ne votez pas
les réformes qui sont proposés qui
devront passer par une révision du bien
sûr nous ne voterons pas mais pas
seulement ça nous allons au début du
mois de janvier nous exprimer les deux
groupes vont s'exprimer ensemble celui
du de l'assemblée et du sénat et nous
allons engager une campagne
d'explication publique dans le pays
parce que tout ça se fait en laissant
totalement à l'écart on est en train de
changer des choses essentielles dont la
viande est ma droite un pack bayer
munich a sans aucun débat rares blick
dans le pays donc il faut mettre les
citoyens dans le coup